[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
new body camera video and a deadly
police shooting politicians promised
transparency
with this release the world will see we
are engaging in an open process
we discuss the law plus a surprise
ruling to allow greater access to the
george floyd murder trials
and a lawsuit in the name of mafia man
whitey bulger
also a boxer's instagram video gets him
in trouble with a judge
and then jodi arius reaches what is
probably the end of the line for appeals
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everybody to law on crime daily
i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
philadelphia police have released body
camera video of the deadly shooting
of walter wallace by an officer they've
also released a series of chaotic 911
calls which said wallace was assaulting
his parents in an apartment
here's how it ended when police
responded to those calls we've frozen
the video when the shots rang out
and blurred the aftermath
put the knock down now put the knife
down now
with the knife down now
[Applause]
that wasn't nice put the knife down now
put the knife down now
put the knife down now put the knife
down
put the knife down back up
back up back up back up man back up
man man back up man
[Applause]
put the knife
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
1866
here is some of another officer's body
camera video someone tries to tell the
police wallace was mental
at one point an officer says shoot him
put the knife down put the knife down
put the knife down man move in
back up put the knife down get him
out
[Applause]
after the shooting one officer is heard
saying wallace was
chasing the police they immediately
tried to clear the crowd to get wallace
to the hospital
and to safely recover the knife
philadelphia's mayor said the violence
surrounding walter wallace's death was
doing
little but helping those who argued that
transparency releasing those videos
was a bad thing we know this moment is
incredibly painful
given so many failures over generations
to protect all of philadelphia's
residents
especially those who are black or brown
as we continue making measurable steps
towards building equity inclusivity and
public safety in our city
releasing this footage as a step but
also an indication an indication of this
failure
seeing another life tragedy lost yet
again to police violence can make many
of us question
whether anything has changed or whether
anything will ever change
but this is why we are releasing this
footage because things have to change
and they are changing and it starts with
our willingness to be transparent
and hold ourselves accountable together
we can show that shining a light on this
issue
will in fact usher in a new day that
brings us greater trust
healing and peace in our city and within
our communities
philadelphia's progressive prosecutor
said walter wallace's mother wanted
nothing more than government
intervention for her son's mental health
crisis
he also reminded people that grand
juries generally decide whether or not
to indict police officers
when a mother was trying to get help
with a situation involving
her son who is blameless for having
mental illness that when she did that
government failed because her son
was killed within a minute of
government's arrival
as a part of government i apologize
for that i think what occurred here is
heartbreaking
so the question then is how does
government not fail now i know that the
police commissioner has promised and i
believe she will deliver
a fair and impartial investigation on
the part of the police department i have
a separate duty
and that is to deliver a fair and
impartial
investigation on the possibility of
criminal charges
in both homicide cases where the
district attorney's office
has found it necessary
to charge a police officer who was on
duty
when he killed a civilian in both of
those cases it was a grand jury
that carefully considered the evidence
over a long period of time and made that
decision
let's jump in now and discuss this this
video brian is sad it's disturbing but
let's look at this as a legal matter
police are justified in using deadly
force under pennsylvania law under
two several under a couple of scenarios
i should say one is to prevent harm
to themselves or another person another
scenario is when it would be impossible
to make an arrest
and a suspect has a deadly weapon and is
trying to either escape
or to seriously harm another so my
question is
does the law protect the officers here
unfortunately i think here the situation
would be that it does um
this is a situation where walter wallace
has a weapon in his hand that being a
knife
and it is readily capable of causing
deadly force
and so the officers have a strong
argument here
as to self-defense it's gonna be a
factual one i think we should see an
indictment i think we should see
charges but i would not have hopes high
if you're expecting
a conviction here so terry same question
for you
should we see an indictment here or do
you think the law protects the officers
well technically the law does protect
the officers
but i think morally it does not what we
need to see is a change in the law
we need to see a change in police
procedures when you have a knife
as opposed to a weapon like a gun
or a you know machine gun i think they
should use as much force as they can to
subdue not to kill so here
in this instance they didn't have to
shoot multiple rounds
they could have you know shot at its
legs they did not have to use deadly
force
so i you know think we need to change
the law
yeah that video again when i key in on
it i'm hearing people say
shoot him and uh we saw the aftermath
and the number of bullets that rang out
and we didn't see
this particular individual lunge at the
police for instance so
there may be some room here potentially
for a grand jury to at least indict but
i tend to agree with both of you that i
think the law is going to favor the
officers here
let's move on now a minnesota judge has
reversed course and will now allow the
high profile george floyd murder trials
to be broadcast to the public four
officers of course are accused of
killing floyd over the summer
the judge said the march 8 2021 trials
of all four
will be held together and can be
recorded by
up to three remote control cameras all
news organizations will
share those cameras the law and crime
network of course applied several months
ago to broadcast the cases
gavel to gattle and still ahead here on
law and crime daily we'll explain why
the u.s government
may have to pay money to the family of
mafia man whitey bulger
but first jodi arias was convicted of
killing her boyfriend
now her appeals process is not playing
out in her favor
a big decision against the infamous
woman is coming up right after this
[Music]
welcome back everybody convicted
boyfriend killer jody arias has pretty
much reached the end of the line when it
comes to appeals
the arizona supreme court this week
refused to review arius's conviction in
the 2008 murder
of her former boyfriend travis alexander
the lower state
court of appeals upheld the area's
conviction a few months back
arius admitted killing alexander but
claimed it was self-defense
prosecutors said it was actually a
jealous rage when
travis attempted to end their affair
special guest michael kiefer is here now
along with brian and terry and i
michael is a writer who's been covering
the area's case so michael the issues on
appeal surrounded prosecutor juan
martinez's ethics
he gave up his law license but contested
accusations he leaked juror information
and harassed clerks did that seriously
affect the arius case in your opinion
yes the the the if you look at the court
of appeals opinion
they it was 29 pages long and nine pages
had to do with jody's case the other 20
pages had to do with juan martinez's
behavior
not just on leaking you know the the
leaking
uh was to uh to to someone in the media
was
uh actually part of the bar complaints
against him not really
as much as in the appeal the appeal um
brought up a whole lot of issues of of
alleged
prosecutorial misconduct which the court
found
they agreed that it permeated the trial
but that it didn't amount
to um they didn't want to reverse a
conviction in a case where they thought
there was evidence of overwhelming guilt
so um the the the recent
arizona supreme court uh opinion was
really
or lack of opinion refusal to take the
case
is really all procedural because you
know rather than this being the end of
the line as arizona goes this is
probably the beginning of her of her
true appeals
uh arizona courts seldom appeals courts
seldom reverse convictions uh throw out
sentences
uh that's going to happen if it happens
it's going to happen
later on now jody's going to go into uh
what they call
is post-conviction relief you know
the as you know the appeals really only
uh work within the confines of you know
the four corners of the trial the trial
record uh post-conviction relief which
is back in a superior court it's the
first
chance they have to bring up um other
information
new information new evidence and to
argue ineffective assistance of counsel
now if you consider the fact that both
the prosecutor
and the um lead defense attorney have
both
uh have both been disbarred they both
surrendered their licenses
mostly based on what happened during
this trial
i think there's a pretty good argument
that could be made that this was an
unfair trial
um that said i still don't think it's
going to happen here in arizona what uh
if
if cases are overturned uh in you know
arizona cases it usually happens in
federal court
up at the uh us knights certainly not at
the state court level okay so terry the
state's highest court said nothing other
than it was simply not taking this case
that's also pretty common right
it's extremely common and i agree 100
with michael you know the fact here that
they looked at the trial court and they
looked at the four corners of that trial
they said there was plenty of evidence
there that she was definitely guilty she
had
a you know confession so you know i
think it makes plenty sense for them to
review it and to decline at that point
and say no we're not going to look at
this
we're going to let the lower court
standing yeah exactly so brian what's
the chance that she could take this to
the u.s supreme court
i mean there's a great chance that you
can take it to the supreme court the
chance of the supreme court actually
taking it themselves is pretty low
i think the supreme court's got a lot
more cases coming up based on this week
that they want to take care of
and the fact that the state court didn't
really want to touch it the supreme
court court's not going to leap over
them and grab it themselves yeah exactly
so
as michael said you know we could see
some action in federal courts here but
this is getting closer and closer to the
end of the line as i said
for jodi arias on appeals michael
appreciate your time here on law and
crime daily
thank you and coming up right after the
break a mother accused of killing her
own autistic son could be forced to pay
with her own life
plus an instagram post by a well-known
boxer gets him in trouble with the law
after he claimed to be nearly broke
those cases and more when law on crime
daily continues
[Music]
a judge in cleveland left a boxer out of
jail two days after holding him there
for not paying eight hundred thousand
dollars to a woman he assaulted
law and crimes angenet levy has more on
the case and what
adrian broner says about paying the
money
boxer adrian broner spent two nights in
jail after a judge held him in contempt
for not answering questions about his
finances in this civil case
we world championships world champions
this video of a table full of cash on
broner's instagram account
caught judge nancy margaret russo's eye
after broner claimed he only had 13
dollars to his name
russo ordered broner to pay a woman 800
000
after she sued him for an assault
outside of a cleveland nightclub in
2018.
that woman said broner pinned her under
his body and kissed her
he was convicted of two misdemeanors for
the assault her attorney spoke with us
about this civil case it's incredibly
frustrating i mean
to to experience an individual who not
only
uh assaults her in such an aggressive
way
but then essentially blows off every
court obligation that he's had
from the beginning i mean including
defaulting on judgment
up until yesterday he was constantly
projecting the figure of a person who
just can't be bothered
by little things like legal requirements
when judge russo asked adrian broner
where he got all of that money he said
that he has
rich friends he also said that he has a
big fight coming up in january and he
believes he'll be able to pay that full
settlement after that
i'm angenette levy for law and crime
daily
broner faces a misdemeanor assault
charge in the cincinnati area he has
pleaded not guilty in that case
and now to several other developments in
criminal cases we're following here on
law on crime daily
law and crimes terry austin is here now
with a case involving the infamous
mobster whitey bulger and a development
in a florida drowning terry erin south
florida prosecutors are now
seeking the death penalty for a mother
accused of drowning
her acoustic her autistic son i should
say
a grand jury indicted patricia ripley
for first
degree murder police say ripley
initially called 9-1-1
to report her nine-year-old child was
abducted by
two men in may 2019. police found
alejandro ripley's body two days later
in a nearby canal
the nine-year-old was autistic and
non-verbal
police say they have evidence the mother
first pushed her son in a different
canal
but a witness rescued the boy
detectives believe she drove to another
canal and completed the drowning
the family of whitey bulger is suing
prison officials after the infamous
mobster
was murdered in prison james whitey
bulger
was serving out a life sentence for the
murder of 11 people
he was well known for organized crime
among irish americans
and returning as an fbi informant to
snitch on his
italian rivals no one has been charged
with his death
and his family says authorities fail to
protect the 89 year old
his family says other inmates with mafia
ties
killed bulgur by placing a lock in a
sock just hours after bogle was placed
in general population
a spokesperson for the burial of bureau
of prisons
declined to comment so terry it's
sort of interesting here because if the
family wins the government will have to
pay a mobster's family
i know that's true you know it seems odd
but if in fact the
prison officials were negligent in a
wrongful death action
there is the right to recover and that
could in fact happen here
it could be the legal outcome so brian
you're following the case of another
infamous defendant for us
yeah so the man known as the golden
state killer has arrived in prison to
start his life sentence
joseph d'angelo pled guilty to 13
murders
and 13 rapes across california in the
70s and 80s
his crimes terrorized the state of
california the former police officer
eluded authorities for many years
until advances in dna analysis linked
him to the crimes in 2018.
he was sentenced to multiple life
sentences in a plea deal
that spared him the death penalty de
angelo was now in the custody
of the california department of
corrections and according to the
department
his final prison placement will be
determined based on his security
medical psychiatric and program needs
nice brian and when we come back the
reading of the verdict in a trial where
a former professional baseball player is
accused of triple murder
our experts on what the defense should
do next when law on crime daily returns
in just a moment
[Music]
a verdict in the trial of a pro baseball
player accused of using a bat engraved
with his own name to murder three people
prosecutors say wanden brandon willie
martin slugged his father his uncle
and a security system installation man
to death martin now faces the death
penalty in a second phase of his trial
the defense already raised mental health
issues but did not argue an
insanity defense in the first or guilt
phase of the trial
the jury deliberated about four hours
here was the verdict california county
of riverside the people of the state of
california versus brennan
[Music]
entitled action by the defendant brandon
william martin
vilcover of michael m has charged under
account two of the amended information
tweeted during the above entitled action
final defendant brandon william martin
delta
murder over ea sergeant
the jury found martin guilty of all
seven charges now comes penalty phase
where the jury will recommend either the
death penalty or life in prison
psychologist and law and crime expert dr
john delatorre says
the defense should conduct a
psychological evaluation of their client
to question
his criminal responsibility
there's some real issues when it comes
to someone being held on a 72-hour
psychiatric hold but then being released
one day
early that's probably not enough time to
stabilize on medications
so i think there were a lot of issues
that kind of fell by the wayside and led
to
this unfortunate incident happening
where this baseball player is not
getting the the psychiatric help that he
needs
it could have been caused by the drug
specifically or it could be
uh self-medicating because he has a much
larger psychotic issue
but either way he should have been
treated better at the hospital
and the defense probably should have had
him evaluated to determine whether or
not
he knew what was right from wrong when
he was committing that act
because it's possible that he has this
delusional idea
that he can never play baseball again
which is why he ended up committing the
crime that he committed
because in his mind those two things are
linked
they need to die and i can play baseball
again and if that's the case
there's some serious psychological
issues that should have been evaluated
terry your thoughts on this certainly
psychological issues i understand that
but what about criminal responsibility
here because the jury found that it
should attach
yeah you know i agree i think at the end
of the day he's convicted and
whether he serves a life sentence in
jail or whether he gets the death
penalty we're in california so we know
there's a moratorium
but i think the real solution here is to
make sure he gets the mental
assistance that he needs as far as you
know drugs or whatever it may be
while he's incarcerated either in jail
or mental health institution
that's the hope now brian what should
the defense do coming up in this next
phase of the case
defense has got to mount a strong
factual as well as a scientific defense
here
to say hey this is what happened
declining mental health
over the course of years was a pro
baseball player one day and the next day
he's being 51.50 and i think the facts
are there
only if as dr delatorre said there they
can get that evaluation and push that
narrative home so if they go ahead and
do that could this potentially just end
in a life sentence then
if they do that and they prove that he
was mentally
insane or this mental disease or defect
if california is similar to like we have
in new york
it's not going to be a jail cell so much
is going to be a mental health facility
it's going to be different services
afforded to him
all right brian and terry appreciate the
insight and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming the
long crime network
is everywhere and we invite you inside
the jury box
this is law and crime
[Music]
you